il fait remonte au 19 novembre 2010 et
se déroule dans l'enceinte du lycée
pasteur de la ville de lagos situé au
nigeria un inconnu se présente devant le
proviseur et lui jette alors un verre
d'acide au visage grièvement brûlée la
victime pascale meyer originaire de
l'yonne a perdu depuis l'usagé d'un oeil
et conserver les séquelles de cette
agression sauvage
très vite les soupçons l'époque se porte
sur slimane s'allie à un enseignant de
philosophie au sein de l'établissement
en 2013 slimane salies se retrouve dans
le box des accusés il est condamné à 10
ans de prison ferme devant les assises
de l'yonne accusé d'avoir commandité
cette agression sauvage
lui qui a toujours nié les faits cette
semaine il va tenter une nouvelle fois
de clamer son innocence devant les
assises de seine et marne
cette affaire avait bouleversé le
personnel du lycée
beaucoup d'enseignants se sont donc
retrouvés de nouveau à la barre
aujourd'hui et ont apporté leur
témoignage au moment des faits slimane
est décrit par ses anciens collègues
comme quelqu'un de manipulateur impulsif
magouilleurs en dehors du lycée ils se
livraient selon certains à des activités
plus ou moins licite des activités
jugées selon le proviseur pascal meyer à
l'époque incompatibles avec son statut
d'enseignant à l'époque pascal meyer
envisage donc de ne pas renouveler le
contrat du prof de philosophie
ces immenses allaient se voir retirer
ces plaques d'immatriculation
diplomatiques
ce qui remet en cause sa position
sociale et porte un coup à ses affaires
l'accusation repose aujourd'hui
essentiellement sur le témoignage d'une
ancienne collègue et amie de l'accusé à
laquelle il aurait fait des aveux
quelques jours après l'agression
je vous propose d'écouter l'avocat de la
partie civile maître stéphane m
moi mon sentiment c'est que à mesure que
défilent les témoins et bien encore plus
qu'en première instance à auxerre j'ai
le sentiment que l'étau se resserre
autour de l'accusé et que les tentatives
de diversion de la défense font chou
blanc bien sûr que on essaye de trouver
et de distiller l'idée qu'il y aurait
d'autres pistes mais décidément ça ne
fonctionne pas ce procès aux assises de
seine-et-marne va se poursuivre jusqu'à
vendredi
le jour durant lequel à slimane salies
sera peut être acquittée dans cette
affaire après l'audience de nouveaux
témoins demain ce seront les charges
matérielles qui seront examinés durant
ce procès